president Trump returns to Harvey's path
today the president makes two stops on
his second visit to the disaster zone in
a week he'll arrive in Houston this
afternoon and then travel to Lake
Charles Louisiana this as the White
House makes its first pitch to Congress
on how to pay for a recovery that could
take months or even years
David beg no is in Houston with the
latest David good morning
Dana good morning we expect the
president to arrive as early as 11
o'clock local time not much is known
about exactly where he's going to go but
the White House is saying he will visit
some type of disaster relief center and
meet with people directly affected by
Harvey and meet with volunteers people
have been so crucial to the good work
that is being done here the president
has already asked Congress for eight
billion dollars in money to help the
folks of Texas now as you said it's his
second trip here he was in South Texas
on Tuesday but he never met with people
directly affected by Harvey he was
criticized for that but the White House
says that was on purpose he didn't want
to get in the way
two days later vice president Mike Pence
went to Rockport Texas you might
remember Rockport took a direct hit from
hurricane Harvey the Vice President did
meet with people affected by the storm
he visited a church that had been gutted
by Harvey when President Trump wraps up
here in Houston he'll head for Lake
Charles Louisiana which also saw a lot
of flooding from Harvey by the time
Harvey rolled into Louisiana it was a
tropical storm and Anthony tomorrow it's
going to be a National Day of Prayer the
president has declared it a national day
for the people affected
David beg no in Houston thank you David